no I'm not about to play a pickup game
of basketball I'm gonna cook no I mean
is great some people don't know now you
know your life is different now all
right I don't know if this video is
gonna see the light of day but I figured
I might um shoot something that I was
going to do anyway and that is bake
tomorrow I'm headed out of town for five
days which means I'm leaving Elliot
behind in Los Angeles for five days so I
thought I would do something nice for
him before I leave something to remember
me by five days is a long time and the
state of the world that we're currently
living in who knows what's gonna happen
in those five days I'm gonna make a very
specifically wonderful treat also he's
home he's in the room over there and
I've asked him not to listen I want to
surprise him with this situation he
knows something's happening but I'm
feeling he's listening and because he
can't help himself so if I whisper
sometimes that's why ASMR lucky you and
by the looks of everything I have
gathered here you might think I'm gonna
make a regular awesome unfed ek yes I am
in a way but I'm making it unique or a
very special human being but I don't
want to tell you exactly what the
outcome is gonna be I want you to watch
along and see if you can figure it out
as we go let's start making some fun
patty cake also I got rid of so much
[ __ ] in my kitchen in an effort to clean
out my whole house that I hardly have
things to cook with I just bought these
off of Amazon a half-hour ago it's the
only Bowl I have left in my house
currently and it's a salad bowl but it
has this area in it open so we will be
mixing everything in here we're just
gonna follow the directions on the box
the decorating is where the unique
loving expression is really gonna come
in to play I love funfetti because I
have trash taste - taste is very trendy
right now that's me to myself by myself
every day this goes in god I already
love it so much it looks like you know
rave cocaine okay
oh I threw the Box away the heavy
goddamn preheat our oven to 300 degrees
got 1 cup of water 1/2 cup of oil I'm
going to use these when you get a really
gross story there was a point in my life
where I would buy funfetti cake batter
and I'd put water in it and mix
and then just eat it with a spoon that
was not a great time in my life well
then three a watch great and we mix it
you've a mixer mix it if you don't mixer
we really do need gun control I have a
whisk this looks so good yeah we're
going to load up our pans to cook it and
normally if you're making regular
funfetti you can make cupcakes you can
make just round regular cakes I'm making
a more abstract scenario here so I have
this meat loaf pan I don't know the
appropriate name fill up a little bit of
the way and then I'm gonna make some
cupcakes this is a very terrible bowl to
pour it even though I got rid of 12,000
items in my kitchen I somehow kept a
melon baller these are gonna go in the
oven now for Oh 15 to 20 minutes and
check in on them I'll put a toothpick in
and see if it slides out clean it's so
many sexual innuendo good luck my
treasure in the meantime we're going to
make sure it's not poisoned Wow eating
lawful whiskeys the grossest thing
oh I'm excellent at doing things I know
it's got raw egg in it you have raw egg
in it if you're a lady you know I'm
talking about upppppp
Rose let's test it okay they look like
they've been cooking basically what I
hear is you put one of these toothpicks
in you pull it out that's got [ __ ] on it
it's not done if it doesn't have cheese
on it
okay cupcakes are done meatloaf cake
needs some more time and be right back
oh sorry I brought to update you that
the meatloaf cake is done everything is
out of the oven
we are going to let it cool down and mix
you're done I put them in the freezer to
cool down really quickly because I'm an
impatient little [ __ ] and now we're
gonna decorate and this is where it all
comes together so I'm just gonna show
you this in a beautiful artistic montage
[Music]
tada we did it you get it
I'm a genius oh I want to cover it great
hey Elliot you wanna come see your
surprise do you want to come see your
surprise because I'm leaving are you
okay good you can take this off be
careful you can be louder Dickon it's a
penis intestine a B thank you I'm so
excited it's a penis sentence because
you're yeah what color are the balls
yeah so I know people that are
colour-blind out there can you tell them
what color the balls the balls are blue
balls thank you yeah welcome this took
way too long to do do you like it I love
it thank you guys for watching I don't
know if they'll let me post this video
but subscribe if you've made it this far
and go check out Elliot over at the
valley yeah go for it you can taste it
I'm curious which part you uh attempt to
eat right symbolically I'm gonna try to
take care the blue balls yeah do it
right
yeah you know thank you hypothermia now